okay so welcome everyone uh thanks for
joining us today today we're
very lucky to have dan alon from tel
aviv university
speaking on distance approximation for
graph properties
so um please bye
okay so first thing is that since it's
it's the first time i'm giving this talk
then and already found a typo on the
first slide
so so please if you see typos or maybe
just write them down
and then you send them to me um so
okay so here goes and hopefully there
won't be too many typos
um so also i'll say i kind of
contemplated
whether i should give a more like
survey-ish
talk or at least talk about distance
approximation in different contexts and
then
i found that i was kind of spreading too
much so i'll talk mainly about
one result but there'll be quite a bit
of background
so um so in this background also maybe
i'll kind of you know take a site or a
little bit i'll say something that is
not
specifically about the result and this
way also there will be also can
we'll give you more background about
about then the context
okay so let's start with the general
context um
so i'll be talking about subliner
algorithms uh so what do i mean here
because there are various types
uh so um we have query access to some
object o
and we want to perform some computation
that is approximately correct
we want to do it with high and high
probability here will be constant you
know we can boost the probability if we
like but it will be simple for me to
think about it high constant probability
and we want to make as few queries as
possible so just a illustration
this blob here is the object and this is
us
and we perform queries and we do some
computation and then
we we output something uh so to define
this task precisely then we must specify
quite a few things we need to say you
know what is the object we're interested
in
what is the query access what kind of
computation we want and what is our
notion of approximation
okay so let's start with saying and
we'll go in more
narrowly from this from some linear
algorithms to property testing and this
approximation so the title of this talk
is about distance approximation but
really it sits
beside property testing and to have the
right uh
to the right context you really have to
talk about both um until they talk about
the new results so in property testing
the task this is i'm talking about what
is the computational task that we want
to perform
in a sublinear manner it's approximate
decision so that kind of
sounds like your first hearing doesn't
mean the product decision is yes or no
it can't
be approximate well what we mean here is
that we want to distinguish between
objects that have a certain property and
those that are
far from having the property as far as
with respect to some pre-specified
distance measure and in distance
approximation
the task is to actually approximate the
distance to the property
okay and there's also a notion of
tolerant testing but i'm just mentioning
it
here in in case that sounds more
familiar maybe they're closely related
but i'll be talking about
distance approximation and in both i'll
also stress that
for both we allow small constant failure
probability
and to define tasks precisely we still
have a few things to specify but maybe
i'll maybe i'll stop once in a while
to see if there's uh there's a question
about the general the general setup
before i kind of go more inside
okay and as i said before you can just
you know
you can just barge in and um and and
talk
and just yourself say something and
that's uh
that will be that's fine with me okay so
i'm going to talk about
property testing and distance
approximation off now i'm going to talk
about the type of
objects that i'm interested in and then
also about the query access the distance
measure so i'll talk about graph
properties and i'll talk about in the
adjacency matrix model okay so first
when i say graph property i just mean
it's a property that is invariant
under isomorphism and it'll be
convenient to me when i say
property i think of the set of graphs
that have the property so then i'll say
g belongs to the property then
this is that belongs to the set of
graphs that have the property
now okay so we've decided on what the
object is
but there are various models uh when we
talk about graph properties
and they vary in the type of queries and
the distance measure it's related to the
way they're
represented and here i'm going to focus
only on that adjacency matrix model
so in this model the graph is
represented by n
is the number of vertices by an n by n
adjacency matrix so just if there is
there's an edge between u and v
there's a one if there isn't there's a
zero
now then what are the queries we are
allowed so this is kind of
straightforward given
the the representation we can ask
whether there's an
edge between u and v uh and we get yes
or no depending kind of it's a probe
into the
jccc matrix and what about the distance
measure
the distance measure is the fraction of
entries
in the matrix that we must modify to
obtain the property
and we denote it by delta gp so again if
the graph has a property
it's just zero and if it doesn't have
the property
then either we need to to modify
add or remove edges and here the
fraction
is with respect to the size of this of
the representation of this object
with respect to n squared and again kind
of in passing
there are other models that uh uh that
in which the both the queries and the
distance measured are different but this
is
this is the model i'll be interested in
so now
once i i said what what are the objects
what is the queries and distance measure
let's just kind of recall
kind of how does it fit when we talk
about property testing and distance
approximation
and from here on i'll i'll use the
shorthand pt
for property testing and d a for
distance approximation
so the property testing algorithm and
it's given query to the adjacency matrix
and it should decide whether the graph
has the property
or whether it is far so we have to the
fraction of entries we need to
modify is bigger than epsilon epsilon is
the
given um distance parameter and
the distance approximation algorithm
should actually output an
estimate of this of this value so it
should output
delta hat where the this the difference
between delta hat and delta
is at most epsilon okay so one is
decision and one
is approximation okay
question in the no case do you also
require an approximation or
or not so in in the you say when it's
when it's in the property testing when
it's far
when it's far yeah when it's far no i
mean i mean for distance approximation
in the case where you have the f i
no matter what it is no matter what it's
not only that if
it's not too far or it is for it i mean
there's no there's no promise here
in in property testing you see does also
i said it's approximate decision it's
also can be said a decision with a
promise
so in in the until the promise is that
either it has a property or it's far in
the middle
we don't really care so here there's no
there's no promise it can be
whatever it is we want to approximate it
well
okay so the the two versions you stated
neither is they're not comparable like
not one
okay okay so so a good point so so and
we'll see
so if so distance approximation i want
to say if i want to say if i'll say it
in one sentence
then i'll say that distance
approximation is
i would say harder or not easier than
property testing but there is a kind of
there is a subtlety here is that uh
whether when you just define property
testing do we allow two-sided
error one-sided there that's uh so here
when i when i talk
here this contour will be two-sided you
you you have you can air in both
directions also if it has a property or
also
if if if it doesn't um and then
in in that sense it's uh so if you have
a distance approximation algorithm then
you you you have a property testing
algorithm with two-sided error
okay good anymore
okay so okay so just uh this is this is
where we stand
and now i'm going to start giving some
background on
uh both property testing and distance
approximation
um and i'll say from start it's not
exhaustive
and it's also not chronological so it's
really it's more to serve my purposes so
in in the sense of putting the result i
want to talk about
uh to say you know what is that the most
relevant background are there lots of
works on probably testing in the in this
model then i'm going to say what is most
relevant
for me so first there's and first again
it's not the first result
chronologically but it's the
the most general result uh that is known
uh by lund fisher newman shapira um and
maybe it's something you have heard of
may not and and that the title of the
paper uh
it's all about regularity there's a sub
there's a there's a subtitle
uh but what uh what they show is they
give a characterization
of all the properties that are testable
with a number of queries it depends
only on epsilon so the point here is
there's no dependence on the size of the
graph
um and it's only a function of f of
epsilon
so i i won't talk about this
characterization detail it's it's it's
quite it's uh
non-trivial um but what i'll say is that
it uses the regularity lemma
so the point here it's very general it
characterizes so the both directions
um but because it uses a regularity
lemma
this function f of epsilon again only
depends on epsilon but it's pretty high
so it's a tower of
height polynomial uh so again if you
don't know
um what the real irregularity limit
doesn't really
matter right now but i'll just say but
if if you do then kind of it will
it will be familiar this expression of
the tower so again general result
um but with very high so tower or two to
the two to the two and
the height is polynomial and one over
can
epsilon
and
a can you give an example of this kind
of properties
oh yeah so we'll see we'll see lots of
properties in in a minute
so we'll so we'll see noah but i'll
throw for now say
um uh so actually you can some of the
properties that i'll mention
are actually have better complexity like
color ability you want to know whether
the glass the graph
is well let's even start with bipartite
you want to know whether the graph is an
ipad type or spark from vitro
you want to know whether it has no
triangle
or whether it's triangle free or
non-triangle-free so
and so this is these are kind of two uh
kind of uh
basic examples that will also come up as
we go as we go along
thank you um and i'll mention there is
another it was an independent result
that got also characterization
using um using graph graph limits okay
so this was property testing
general result but a bit a bit costly
but very general
now when we go to distance approximation
fischer and neumann
showed uh actually also a very general
result about distance approximation
they showed that every property that has
a that has a property testing algorithm
with dependence only that depends on
epsilon
has a distance approximation algorithm
also with dependence only on epsilon
and here the complexity is even higher
uh so wowzer
is like a tower this is kind of a
recursive definition of towers of towers
so this is
if tower is high wow is like really high
but still it is again it says something
very general only depends on epsilon no
depends no depends on
n and uh if you want if you want
general but maybe slightly less general
uh then there are results for um for
i'll use my cursor this is really good
so for pretty general but still more
restricted
monotone properties and the properties
that are maintained
under removal of vertices and edges and
hereditary there
that are maintained under uh removal of
of vertices
still it's better not wowzer and
uh but still uh it's towers of height
the best you can get is tower of height
poly log on reps on which is you know
great improvement but still
pretty high so general results this is
kind of what you get from here
general results come at a cost
okay so then you say well you want to do
these big functions you know you don't
want to hear about these big functions
you want um
you want polynomial or even you know
here since those functions are so high
even you know exponential one level of
exponent is fine but uh really we want
one poly one over epsilon
and here so first i'll talk about what
is known about testing
in this for poly one over epsilon and
then i'll talk about distance
approximation
uh so for testing now i'm going back
back in in
kind of in history uh to the first paper
that explicitly
talked about uh uh uh testing graph
properties in the adjacency matrix model
and here in this paper we showed
actually that you can get
poly one over epsilon query complexity
property testers
for a general family of partition
properties so i won't define this family
here
i will actually later talk about a
subfamily so you'll get a feel for what
i mean here
and here i'll just say that it contains
k colorability row cut which means do
you have the properties do you have a
cut off
size at least of at least row and
squared edges crossing the cut
row clique do you have a click of size
of these row and so on there's it's a
big family but it contains
um pretty much you know i don't know if
you say the natural
pro partition properties that you would
like you would be interested in so you
can get
probably one of epstein um for this
family
um alone looked at atrinos
here non-induced again you want to know
is the graph
a tree so you're given a constant size h
say a triangle i'm not saying this so
we'll see what i can say about triangle
and you want to say no is it um is it uh
uh free from this uh from this uh
subgraph and what he showed is a
dichotomy
he showed that uh you have a poly one
over epsilon and again here i talk about
queries maybe that's a good
point to say that i'm interested in not
that i don't care about time
but queries are really the main issue
and and definitely for that for the
partition properties uh since they are
related to hard problems
then you can't expect to have poly one
over epsilon
uh time so focus is really
it's kind of is queries say you know how
much
you have to look at the graph to make we
make a
uh make a decision uh so now returning
to
to nova loans work so he showed that if
the graph
the graph the sub graph that you want to
be free of
is bipartite then you have a polymor
universe so testable algorithm
if it's not then you don't that's really
and what is
kind of a striking here i think is again
for people who kind of were maybe yeah
people work in combat tourists maybe
they uh they it would be they wouldn't
think it's so surprising but i think
from outside it's a
even like the simple you know property
that i mentioned before triangle
freeness no
what's the big deal being triangle-free
you really require you
must have super polynomial on the other
hand if you have like it's even a small
but bipartite you have a
c4 you know uh then it is probably one
reps on so
these things kind of show you it's not
really yeah it's not really clear what's
easy
what's hard and so one more thing as i
promised that i'll kind of one i'll take
i'll take small side tracks
uh so tribal phoenix know there is a
super polynomial but still there's a big
gap
you know even if somebody showed
something you know exponential that
would be or even
doubling i would be interested because
the upper bound is much higher
it's uh it's a tower of log one rep so i
think this is the best known
result right now okay now i
i said that alone talked about uh
non-induced induced atriums
and uh with the sub shapiro they worked
on induced age penis
and here what they showed uh that
inducation
is not poly one over epsilon testable
for every h
with very few exceptions so here it's
well well in that in the non-induced
case you have a dichotomy some you have
some you don't
here it's really almost everything there
is a super polynomial lower bound
but there are these p2 just an edge
p3 path of length three pathology four
and a cycle of length four these are the
the only ones uh which were
there they showed there isn't a negative
result
so this is kind of it's mostly a
negative result here but it leaves
open and a few positive questions and
indeed
other complements so this is this is uh
kind of uh
natural that if you can't do one you
can't do the other
so and what about positive okay that was
pretty negative
and what about positive results for
these specific
disease-specific graphs so other p2 is
just an edge so that's really that's
very easy
uh but also all the other ones p3 p4
uh have poly one over epsilon c4 has
exponential poly epsilon and chordality
which i'll talk a little more at the
very end
and i mentioned it here it's a subset of
c4 freeness i won't say exactly what it
is now but i'm interested in it
as i mentioned it here and this was in a
sequence of several works
so respectively kind of each one of
these was was uh shown in a different uh
okay so just to kind of say where we
don't have to remember whenever i'll
need
one of the things here in the background
i'll remind you so you don't have to
remember
uh but basically there are strong
negative results and but are there are
also some positive results for
these specific subgraphs of interest
okay so this was testing what about
distance approximation again probably
one over epsilon
um so here there is less is known uh so
now from this point on
us and i'll use ggr um
and instead of the three names so my
rule is
first two times you get a name
afterwards you don't
um and so the focus in this work was
on property testing as i said but as a
subroutine
um the paper includes an algorithm for
approximating
the size of the max k cut so you want to
partition to k sets and you want the
number of edges
to maximize the number of crossing edges
so here you might be a little worried
hey just a minute this is a hard problem
you might have been worried before also
about this with the testing
but but um but note here that the the
type of approximation
that we we we get here is within an
additive epsilon n
squared so it's not a multiplicative
approximation so
so that's one point and again and also
it's it's
probably one of our epsilon queries and
this says
in particular it says maybe a little
more but in particular it says remember
we talked about k
colorability as one of the partition
properties so
we do have poly one graph so query
distance approximation for
you know kind of well-known natural
property of k color ability so we have
this is one i'm sorry one positive
result that we have for distance
approximation
okay now i'll say a couple of things are
kind of immediate but still we have to
kind of to see where we stand so p2 is
just an edge so that's really trivial
but actually we you can transform the
the results
from um from the testing to distance
approximation for all bipartite atrium
and non-induced
basically by approximating the number of
edges so this is this is this is
easy on the other hand this is related
to the
the question that was asked before and
all the hardness results since they hold
for
two-sided two-sided uh property testing
the hardness results for property
testing also transform
so we get we get this kind of for free
uh hardness uh hardness to hardness and
one more thing uh that i mentioned on on
the positive side
so one of the papers that actually
appeared appeared before
uh hopefully not l and their result with
some additions applied distance
approximation algorithms now this is
going to be
important for my context four remember
those properties before
p3 and p4 freeness induced
with exponential poly one over epsilon
and for c for freeness and codality with
double
exponential poly1 over epsilon okay so
i'll remind you of this
so this is kind of i think this is i
don't have here so this is what we know
about distance approximation
we know 4k colorability can be done in
poly there are some easy things that can
be done
and for those properties that we don't
have a lower bound
for for a polynomial then uh
that there are results but they're at
least exponential or even double
exponential okay so this is this is
where we start coming in and again i'll
remind you
so now i'll stay with our results in and
then i'll pause to see if you want me
to remind you something
sorry question sorry uh i may have
missed this but
um how does n exactly enter in all of
this i mean oh okay
this is good and again and don't worry
if you i think it's really important
even
whether i said it explicitly i didn't
say it i think if something you miss
something then i really i do want you to
to to stop me because i think i know i
find it if i it throws me off and then i
can't concentrate and i think also other
people probably
did so any case with that being said so
n is the number of
vertices but in terms of the complexity
of the algorithm the number of queries
it does not
in all of these cases does not depend on
n so there's no it only depends
on on epsilon so basically you
you look only at a very small subgraph
based on that you make decisions about
the whole graph and
it does not depend and it means it
scales i mean there's no problem with
scalability with n
there's only dependence on one over
epsilon okay but then a quick follow-up
on that is if i
allowed the algorithm to depend say
logarithmically on n
can can the dependence on it this is
really a good question so
it's quite interesting that actually
there aren't
there are hardly any results in property
testing
in which the dependence on n
really gives you gives you something but
i want to be careful about this i
can't really say that i'm sure that
there you can't get a trade-off
i have to be nominated i'll be careful
about this if something is if i remember
kind of asking myself
i'll say two things one is there are the
only results
that actually have an explicit
dependence on and
in this the dense model not in others um
are for isomorphism that's uh there's uh
the results that depend on end they're
lower bound so
really you must have a dependence all
other results in this model do not
so then you ask but maybe you can do
some trade-off
and here i want to be here about be
careful i remember asking myself and i
don't remember if
the answer was that i in the end that i
don't know if you can have a trade-off
or
whether it was whether it was and maybe
one more thing that i'll mention
there are um non-naturally you can get a
hierarchy so this is maybe
when i think about properties i think
about natural ones but there is
work that shows kind of for a hierarchy
of that for every complexity you have a
property
that is uh this is its query complexity
but it's for made-up problems so it's
not so i think it's good to know that
there is this hierarchy
but it's not for natural ones so so
there is there are results in which
there is dependence on
n but in a non-natural way okay so this
is kind of fun so i hope i answered
yeah thanks okay so so maybe another
question in this topic
so the distance is normalized by n right
right right by n
squared right right right okay right
right right
this is really thanks
yeah so this is really important because
it means it's meaningful for dense
graphs
so if you want to talk about sparse
graphs then you should work in a
different model
and the results there are are quite
different it's uh also in
the testing maybe i'll you know i said
that i'll you know in the worst case if
i won't have time for all i wanted
that's okay i think i'd rather
tell you things that you're interested
in so just but i think so something for
example
for the property i mentioned before of
two colorability that is bipartiteness
um so if you talk in this model uh
you really you need just a small
polynomial it's one of epsilon squared
queries
as suffix for for testing so really you
look at a very small subgraph
and if you can distinguish between being
bipartite and
being far according to the small
subgraph on the other hand
if you want to talk about sparse graphs
so in sparse graphs um
you uh you want really you will
normalize this is that natural
normalization will be with respect to
the number of edges not
n squared you know if it's sparse then n
squared that it's not meaningful
so if you do that and you work in a
different query model
then uh you suddenly have a dependence
on n there's
upper and lower bounds that are related
to square root of n
in the in the more general model so it's
it's it's
model dependent density dependent so
there is uh
but definitely this is really important
that it's with respect to n squared
meaningful for dense graphs okay
thank you yeah sure can i say what is a
query
theory just check whether an edge is
there or not or you can do something
more surface yeah that's the query the
query the query here in this model
is just you give the name of two so you
know you know
n so let's call the vertices are named
one through n
you give that oracle i j or the
or you probe into the adjacency matrix
and you ask is there an edge or isn't
there okay
basically the type and the type of
things you can do so you
you can you can do a little more but
basically you you take a
sample of vertices and you look at the
induced subgraph and
you decide based on that and this is as
opposed to other models in which you can
do more
sophisticated things like you know
random walks bffs
stuff like that are they curious they're
adaptive or not
so they may okay so they may be you are
allowed though here here adaptivity
won't be relevant
okay again if you want to really once
you get into the
subtleties of like what polynomial of
one over epsilon
adaptivity may help but if you're not if
you know polynomial is going up to you
square it though additivity is not but
if you really you start going to the
uh then and actually i think that's
interesting too but here
we're talking about big polynomials so
it's uh
and relativity is not really uh and then
in the other model it is because you
walk in the graph you really
you're adaptive by nature you have to
you know you get a neighbor you want to
continue you have to know its name
so but here yeah and not it's it's not
adaptive
thanks okay okay
so what are results so what we do is we
describe the kind of methodology
for designing decision uh distance
approximation sorry algorithm
it's based on a notion of property
coverage which which i'll talk about
and then we apply this uh to obtain
distance approximation algorithms
for p3 p4 and
chordality uh with poly one over epsilon
queries
and for c4 freeness with exponential and
poly one over epsilon queries
so now this is a good point to compare
to remind you of how this compares to
previous work also one important thing
here since i talked about
h venus both induced non-induced there's
a difference so
here i'm talking about induced right
induced induced
uh freeness so but i won't say the word
induced i'll just say free
um so one thing to to point out here is
that it matches
the property testing results for these
properties so
the same same complex again not exactly
the same polynomial even in one case we
get a better polynomial but just because
we were i mean it's it's not
uh then in that result they didn't make
an effort
it just happened that we got to build a
better polynomial but that's not the
main issue
but it's really the same structure for
these three properties
there's poly testing poly distance
approximation and for c4 it's x poly
and if we uh compare it to what was
known for distance approximation
then we improve exponentially or in one
case even a little more than that
so just here i'll i'll remind you that
the previous results show
that p3 and p4 was x quality we get poly
and for c4 and modality they get double
x but here even for cadal
we get poly and so it's both matching
at for testing and it's um it's uh
an improvement okay so question at this
point before i start kind of i
jump in into how questions
do this yeah a piece uh p3 freeness
that you've been uh counting piece
number of p3s in the graph no it's not
it's not
counting it's not counting them uh but
it's rather
uh but it's rather we'll see in a uh
wait a minute
five minutes i'll get you'll see what p3
is it's it's different from
from counting them right because the
measure here is the number of
edges that you need to remove
or add in order to make it p3 free it's
a different notion than
counting because that's associated to
the number of p3 which is respect to n
cubed so it's a different it's a
different note okay
okay any other questions i mean maybe
maybe you'll get to this later
but i mean is it a coincidence that
you're matching the result for property
testing or are you doing some sort of
reduction into property
not a reduction um we
we do build on the these underlying
structures uh which we use and we also
use in the property testing
but it's not it's not by injection so it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't clear that even if we use
those
probably it will really give us it will
give us the same
so this is uh and actually i would say
we even we hoped at some
point uh that we actually will improve
for the c4 freeness we kind of thought
we had
something that will even give the poly
one reps on for c4 which is the only one
about now these that is
exponential poly um and um yeah so it's
not it's not by reduction so
so again i can't say exactly coincidence
because of the structures but it's um
it's not by reduction okay thanks okay
so let's start with so so okay so let's
see what will be the structure let me
look at the time but okay
so i'll start by talking about property
covers
uh this notion um and then i'll start
and then i'll show how we use them
in order to to get our results while i
give a couple of
examples okay so um
now i'm going to define this notion of
property cover
so p will denote a property f family of
properties epsilon is our distance
parameter
and we say that f the family of
properties is an epsilon cover per p
if now i'm going to it's going to appear
in a statement but also i'll have an
illustration in a minute so some people
prefer
to see things in in kind of a formal
form some illustrations so
i'll give both okay so the first thing
we want that the cover
cover will have is that for every graph
in the property
this is our property that we want to
cover
there exists a property in the cover
such that
um our graph is close epsilon over two
close to that to that property so that's
one thing
and the other thing is kind of in the
opposite direction uh for every
graph g prime that is in the union of
all these properties
we want it to be close to our uh to
uh to our property so let's look at i
think an illustration for me at least it
happens
i need to concentrate when i have more
than one quantifier usually i need
to concentrate okay so let's this
illustrates p
that's our property and now this is here
we have three
uh properties in my family f and what do
i mean that they
they cover here uh so um basically well
when you look at it it seems like you
know kind of the symmetric difference is
small but it's not exactly that
so let's see what it is exactly so first
for the first
um first condition that we asked here we
say for every g
in in the in the property p we want
there to be
a property p prime in the cover that it
is close to so it's not really
nicely it's not really covered by by by
the cover so i thought that everybody
in p is in some property in the cover
but it's close to it
and we also need the other direction so
we also need to show
uh rather show we need the second
condition
if g prime is in some p prime again it
doesn't necessarily have to be
in p or in some cases it will be but
again it is close to p
so in both directions they're kind of uh
semi-tight cover
that's kind of the um idea
so any questions about this definition
because this will be something else
that'll be important for me
okay so i'll return to it if you'll want
to i'll return to this picture if you
need to yeah again um and
now we have a claim that is not
complicated but it will be really useful
for us
and it i'll state it roughly and the
reason roughly because if i state it
exactly then it will be
really tedious so i'm kind of you know
brushing kind of
the quantifiers aren't precise a few
things aren't precise but i think it's
it's more intuitive
when it's uh approximately this way so
what does it say
if i have a graph property p and i have
f of epsilon on purpose i want to
remember that it depends on epsilon for
you know for for different epsilons we
can
the covers have to you know may be
different f epsilon is an epsilon cover
for p
so what do i know suppose i have a
distance approximation algorithm for
every p prime in my cover and it makes
q of epsilon phrase then the rough
statement is
that i have a distance approximation
algorithm for my property
and the number of it makes roughly the
same number of queries
up to a dependence logarithmic
dependence on the size of the family
so this is kind of if you want you see
this log and you say oh that's kind of
you know
log union bound yes it comes from
basically a union bond
and so basically if i want to say two
words how how this is proved
it's a combination of a union bound and
triangle inequalities
so this is uh so in order to see how it
works exactly then then
one has to write the quantifiers
precisely and a few other things you see
why can't we use uh
uh new environment but this is this is
roughly this is they'll be roughly the
idea so
the claim again if i have a cover
then i'm pretty i'm doing pretty well if
it's not too big
again i'll depend on the side the cover
and i have a
distance approximation for everybody in
the cover then i'm pretty
kind of i'm doing pretty well i can get
uh and
i want to say another thing this in
retrospect when looking at previous
works even though with the regularity
lemma in the distance approximation they
had implicit covers but they weren't
explicit and also you know it's not easy
to go into and see
define the covers there but it's there
is so it's kind of one of the things
we're
making it explicit and also you know it
might remind you of things so i think
it's pretty different but
it at first you know first reading it
maybe still like you know
like an epsilon that but not quite it's
but it reminds you of other things that
probably
you you've seen you've seen in the past
so it's a pretty natural not complicated
notion
maybe this direction is less is less
intuitive but it's important here for
for uh for one of the triangular wallets
okay so
questions about the statement though i
haven't proven it
i think i can understand that if this is
non-adaptive curious because basically
it's
a unique probabilistic band but if it's
adaptive
i feel totally you're totally right
that's part of the roughly so actually
the precise thing and which is relevant
this is not a general statement that is
not for
so actually the more precise one is
exactly using that you're totally right
using the non-adjectivity
of that really what these algorithms for
these properties do
they take a sub graph uh they they
sample vertices uniformly at random look
at their sub graph
and decide so the queries are not
adaptive and this is definitely you're
totally right because otherwise
it would be you wouldn't have a log
factor you would have so the
point here is that since they all in
terms of their queries not in terms of
the decision in terms of queries they do
the same thing they take examples of
it's enough to take a bigger sample so
that we can reduce the the
uh the failure probability of each of
them so this is you're
totally right this is uh so this is one
of the things yeah that i'm
behind the other thing is the
quantifiers here with epsilon so this is
even more
this is a crucial thing you're right and
this is something that i'm using that
works out
for property testing of graph properties
that may be problematic elsewhere
so it's not uh i can't say it's totally
general yeah
so thanks any other questions
okay so good so so now we have we have
we made us an important step
in in the sense that what we want now is
cover so we have our properties
and we want to find these families that
are known to be easy or
we can show that they're easy uh um to
to get a
distance approximation and in and the
families i'm going to talk about
i'm going to call them semi-homogeneous
partition products it's a long name but
it's not very complicated
and now i'll remind you earlier on i
said that ggr
talked about partition properties these
are a subclass
of these properties and they are pretty
easy to define
and on first thing i think that's i find
this kind of interesting
so that there's a difference you know p3
p4 freeness what does that have to do
with partition so we'll see
but i think that's kind of nice that the
cover the the
family that covers doesn't sound like
something that
is related to the property on on first
hearing and then you'll see why it is
okay so what are these properties
so each property in this family is
defined by an
integer k in k think so think of k
colorability k
cut and a symmetric function so here it
is specific here the function is
from pairs i j uh i and j
h and k to zero one and bottom we'll see
what this means
and um so a graph has
the corresponding property which i'll
denote by p sub phi
so phi is my is my function that defines
the property
and so it has a property p sub v if
there exists a partition there's a
partition
of the graph vertices into k sets again
i'll also you'll have an illustration
soon such that for every i j
what holds if phi i j
is zero then there are no edges
at all between v i and v j if e i j
is one then there are all edges this is
the homogeneous
notion that there is a kind of for every
also for ion itself ion
can be if if i i is zero it's it's an
independent set if
i i is one it's a clique and then you
say what about bottom
that's the semi so you're also if
there's no constraint
then you know you can have whatever you
like so we and we need that
so one thing to say before i show an
illustration so one thing to say here
um is that uh k colorability is
is a good simple example for this
basically just fee
i i is zero you have k sets those are
the colors
zero inside and then other than that you
can have whatever you like
uh but more generally let's say i hope
i'll i'll i'll explain kind of the
the texture codes here for this example
so here i have k
equals three so it's v1 v2 and v3 and
suppose that
here this is a clique this is an
independent set
this is a clique and i can do that with
a pii
and between one and two there's
a complete bipartite graph between one
and three there are no edges
and this little wavy thing uh represents
that
whatever you like between v2 and v3 so
you can you can represent here things
that are more
general than coloring but they have kind
of they have the spirit
the spirit of of coloring okay so
questions about this definition
if you want to kind of digest it a bit
okay so when i'll use the notation that
i'll use the notation
s h p p k a semi homogeneous partition
properties of size
of size k um and now there is
uh what can i say about this i said you
know i want a family
that will be easy and indeed easy i mean
easy by what we know or
about what we can show and there's a
level showing
the saying that for every uh partition
property of this type semi-homogeneous
it has a distance approximation
algorithm whose query complexity is
polynomial one over epsilon that's good
and logarithmic and k actually this
logarithmic and k and some of our
results is really important it's not
linear in k but it's logarithmic in k
and this might sound
but i don't want it it sounds in the
middle and getting confusing and
counterintuitive
because you know you have to depend on k
at least linearly well
you don't really and and i i think i'd
rather not get into this
why so maybe i'll leave it to think and
if you want you can send me email later
that i'll
that'll explain i'll just say you can
prove this lemma either directly by
adapting
one of the ggr results or indirectly
by uh by showing that it's related to
these constrained satisfaction problems
which takes a little to see but once you
see it then it's uh it's almost that
and and and using a work that we have
before
okay so we define these properties we
know that each of them has a distance
approximation so
putting this together the quarterly
correlation is sorry
if a property has an epson cover in this
family and again
the family um in this
that is a semi-homogeneous partition
property and it depends the cover
depends on epsilon
also k the number of parts depends on
epsilon this is important
then by combining with the claim we had
before
about about covers then we have a
distance approximation algorithm with
query complexity depends on polynomial
and one over epsilon
logarithmically on the number of parts
logarithmically on the size of the
family
so this will already um okay i'm looking
at the time
um already you can kind of see that this
is gives us kind of
uh what it helps there's here's a
polynomial here it allows us
that the covers will be pretty big not
both in terms of the family and also
the number of parts so we can be the
number of parts may be exponential
our result will still be polynomial and
the size of the family will be
exponential
and probably one grab some and we'll
still we'll still be fine if it's more
than that then we'll
we'll start paying but this is something
that both these things are important for
for our results so questions about this
corollary okay good so
now that we have so we have in our hands
uh this notion of semion just partition
properties corollary that tells us you
know
just find a cover find a cover not too
big not too many parts
and then you can and then you can use it
uh in order to
uh to uh compute the distance
approximation
so what we'll do now is i'm going to
we'll see how much
how much time it will take and my plan
was to talk about so
p3 freeness and this is there was a
question before so it's a good
p3 p3 freeness is really it's easy
but i think it's good to see something
easy and also since i might not have
that much time for the harder ones
then we'll go through this and then i'll
in the time i have i'll talk about
about p4 freeness so it's easy but uh it
will give
us um a feeling of things so
so i i want to go through it kind of in
detail
even it will take us some okay
so our starting point is a combinatorial
fact
i mean known fact a graph is p33
if and only if it consists of disjoint
clicks
okay and this you can check this you can
check for yourself
that uh that this is really in both
directions it's kind of so it's uh um
you know i don't like giving exercises
and talks but still i think it's a it's
a it's a you know it's kind of a
nice and and simple one so so it's
really uh
to to check that this is really a
characterization of p3 and again
remember it's induced so right so you're
not allowed to have this path
and you can have other sub graphs over
three vertices so you can have a
triangle that's good
and you can have an edge and a separate
vertex and you can have three separate
vertices
okay so then you say hey just a minute
you know why did i
why do i have all this slide you know am
i not done
i mean this side
it's pretty you know when each part is a
clique and nothing between them
then you know but there's a little cap
because we said we still
if if we want to define this as a
semi-imagined partition property or even
homogeneous because everything here is
there's no bottoms here um then we'll
need a lot of parts in general
in general graph we'll need a lot of
parts and then we'll have you know
maybe it's order n parts then we'll have
a dependence on n this is not what we
want
so we can't just use it exactly
as is but if we think a little more
then we have the following claim the
following claim says
that and that p3 freeness has
and it has an epsilon cover uh f of
epsilon
where the number of parts is just
related
linearly to one of reps on you know here
i was precise one reps on plus one
usually i'm not that you know i don't go
to the plus one but here
it's simple and even the family is just
one property
okay so we'll see this so i claim here
that using this
it's very much it is a semi-homogeneous
but
the k is too big so what we want to do
is use the cover that allows us
kind of to do things approximate um
to get to to to get something that has a
small cover
okay the few parts okay so we're going
to since i said it's
simple the claim let's just prove it in
a few lines
okay so what will be the property what
would mean the cover i said will
contain just one property what will that
property be
um then the property will be will be
defined by
one over epsilon disjoint cliques and an
independent
set and between them nothing between
them so this fits
into my semion genius framework
so this property belongs to if i use
just again this is one of repson cliques
plus one independent set so i have you
know
the proper the the right number of parts
and it's just
one property so the cover is just of one
of one property
but why so it's okay so this is easy to
define but
why does it have why is this a cover
okay let's see this
in detail i want to claim one direction
of the cover says that
every graph in the property that is p33
is epsilon too close to this property to
some graph in in it so
all i'll do is the following i'll take
my graph it has many cliques
and i'm going to just keep biggest ones
i'll take the one over epsilon largest
leaks
and these will fit to my one over
epsilon disjoint clicks
i'll remove all other edges so i'll make
everything else into
an an independent set and again here if
you'll check the
uh i won't do the calculation here but i
i removed
at most epsilon and depends here after
factor of two
i removed uh order epsilon and squared
edges because i
kept the biggest ones so the total
number of edges in all the small ones
is small and i i got and i got what i
wanted so this was in one direction
in the other direction it's even easier
but i'm in the other direction remember
if a graph g prime belongs to the cover
here the cover is just one property
then i want it to be close to my
property but it's actually p33 because
all i did is
i removed removed uh some of the clicks
um and i and oh maybe this important
thing to say
in this definition here i'm allowed to
have tricks for size one nobody said so
the independent set guys will
correspond to just very very small
clicks
um and the last thing and then i'll kind
of i'll let you digest it and see if you
want to um
add something so if i take this cover
corollary from the previous page
then i get the t3 freeness has a poly
one over epsilon query
distance approximation because i said i
need a cover
i depend poly one over epsilon and
logarithmically on k okay that's you
know cheap and logarithmic you're on f
that's very cheap so for p3 freeness i
get
i get by the cover uh corollary i get
what i want
okay so i'll stop for a minute i want to
ask
questions about this
okay so in the few minutes that i have
i will try to give you i guess um
a taste of p4
and um um and it will be
just more to yeah let's let's let's see
what
um how much time i have and if i have it
but if it first i'll stop a little more
do you want to ask anything about this
okay so for p4 i guess we'll have time
is maybe just to
to tell you what is the underlying
structure and
something about the ideas of how how we
you know where it is
less easy than p3 and what else uh
okay so here the fact is that a graph is
p for free
if and only if it has a code tree and i
say okay you know i know
you know clicks before that's fine
poultry and now i'm giving you this new
this new thing so let me just define
what a code tree is
so a co-tree which i don't know why it
is i don't like that name but it's
it's it has been used before i would
call it maybe a cut tree
but it's called a coat tree so a coal
tree of a graph
is a binary tree so and again i'll have
an illustration that might be i might
even add in you know i'll have an
illustration in a minute
there is a one-to-one correspondence
between the leaves of the tree and the
vertices of g so basically the leaves
are the vertices of g
and why do i want to call it a cut tree
the internal nodes
each internal node corresponds to a cut
in
in the graph um where the cut is either
empty or full and you know what let me
go to the illustration i think this is a
little easier
so suppose uh these are my vertices this
is my graph
now i want to just kind of describe the
describe that that the cut tree or
the coat tree so um i'm going to build
the tree
from top down and there are more than
one ways to do it
so i'm going to start with cuts which
i'll do separations and i'll continue
recursively
so i start with one cut which is a
complete
bipartite wrap between this side and
this side
okay so i put kind of the internal node
i write one
one reads full cut all edges now i
continue and i'll
keep i'll put the vertices here a b go
on one side
others on the other side now let's
continue recursively to this side
a b no edges empty cut so
i put a zero here this is that the cut
here
i put something saying no empty cut how
do i continue now
between c and the rest you know there's
more than one way
that's an empty cut so i put a zero
and i have just two more cuts to go here
we have another empty cut
i said three more cuts and between the
other guys we have
uh full cuts so this is every
p4 this is maybe harder to see why this
is true
but every um so maybe at this point i
have very little time and i need to kind
of
wrap up soon so i'll just show you my
nice slides and i'll just say that
looking at this again we have something
similar to what we had before
this sounds like okay you know there are
these sets there are these cuts
homogeneous it sounds like
isn't this a partition property
semi-genus again
it is but unfortunately it might have
too many parts
so the main kind of thing we need to do
and again i'll just kind of
quickly go over this is show that you
can
take that you can take a big tree
like we had before many many cliques you
can take a big tree
and by more complex modifications
we can make it into a smaller tree
by a you know
being here actually removing edges is
enough and just because i
i like my my slides i'm going quickly
and now i you know if anybody wants them
i can send them
and the last thing i'll say here is that
for c4 freeness and codality
and maybe you know the last thing here
i'll just want to say that okay
sorry um okay so let's just i'll i'll
quickly go
through this they're also the what is
common here
we have an underlying combinatorial
structure so we use this
the problem it doesn't fit into the
semi-homogeneous exactly
so now what we
[Music]
do is that we we have over based on this
but we need to do some modifications
so for c344 it's somewhat more complex
we also
use this bottom thing which you know say
why did i need that we need that
um we need to have the covering both
directions
um and we use also the fact that the
k and the size are essential not poly so
i have to recap here and then i'll let
you ask questions and if you want me to
go back i'll be happy
so again we describe methodology for
describing distance approximation
algorithms it's based on what we
call property covers and we apply it to
get
um uh for p3 p4 and chronology poly1
reps on for c4
exponential it matches the property
testing results for these properties so
it's the same
same complexity and it improves on
distance approximation exponentially
and it uses something i didn't say in
the beginning because i didn't define
and uses a particular family of
properties that are partition properties
so some
seemingly unrelated but we find out that
very related
and i think the kind of the main open
question
is it's kind of the last minute that i
have my main open question
is so we said it matches the property
testing results but you know is this the
general thing this is related to what's
really asked so we didn't reduce but
maybe there is something general that
shows there's always a polynomial
relation or maybe
slightly bigger function relation we
don't know this is not the case
actually at some point when i i talked
to odette goldrich
then he said that he thought maybe the
that you can show actually that it's uh
well maybe i'll say one more thing
that in general functions um there isn't
such a um
there is there are properties that are
easy very easy for proper
testing very hard for a distance
approximation very big gap
but we don't know if this is the case
maybe it is you know i don't know i
don't i don't really have
i don't really have a guess here so uh
but this is i think very interesting
what is the relation between them is
there something general
probably will you know even even if it's
not the case
what properties does this hold maybe
we'll need more general covering
and the last little kind of annoying
thing is c4 freeness you know why we
want to get you know that would be the
last we would want to nail it down to
get polymer
so at this point i'll just stop and see
if you want to ask me any more questions
thanks
okay let's thank our speaker by waving
our hands in the air since we can't uh
clap
okay uh excellent does uh do people have
questions you can just unmute yourself
and ask
um i actually do have one question i
mean if while people are uh
kind of gathering their thoughts so so
is i mean
i guess just because you brought up the
regularity lemma
i guess the um like in the regularity
lemma i should think of
instead of having a semi homogeneous um
partition property i have a i mean i can
get a partition but i need like
many different refined levels so so is
is the power here really that you
are identifying properties where like
one zero or don't care
is is enough i think so i think that
there's several things here so first
first under regularity element again
it's generality not only in the
application properties
in general it says you know every graph
every graph
and and every epsilon there is a regular
partition you know lots of parts but
it's it's really quite
amazing so so it's something you do kind
of in advance
every graph has it um and
here there are two things first we don't
claim that
every graph is close to having so that's
one thing
it's things that have the property that
we're talking about
can be covered in this manner and also
it is really that they
are the the the covers we use the family
is really much
is much more restricted it really is so
it doesn't have to be really
zero or one you know very kind of this
homogeneity
is really is really very it's really
really very useful here
and that's what it makes it less general
but
and the question goes somehow in between
there are also different types of
regularity lemmas regular partitions are
more the stronger
weaker and maybe there is something here
that can be i don't know and now i'm
making this up there's some continuity
and
there's some hierarchy of a partition
probably i'm not really sure but you're
totally right that it's a
it's it's really it's it's much stronger
there and
it's you know it holds for all graphs
and here we need something
something weaker that's the power that
we that we take
thank you
so if anybody will want to ask me so and
i am aware that i but it kind of
that i we kind of spent more time at the
beginning but i i think it's
i mean i don't mind that we didn't maybe
it's more important in a sense to
to understand kind of what are the
questions rather than the particular
uh results so uh but if anybody will
want me to
to you know they can send me email to
ask about something
i have a question so here your algorithm
is deterministic so uh is there
possibility to like
have some randomized hours and give
anonymize
not really there is randomization
inbuilt
because we always think maybe it didn't
come out
clearly that's uh yeah because they put
everything was like in these
modular things under the lemmas so it
didn't come out
but these this is approximation they
take a sample they
everything here is is uh is is really
randomized it's kind of
nice uh so sorry this is something that
wasn't so you know there is an algorithm
there is that i don't even say that it's
randomized maybe because i'm
so kind of so used to it then you really
you must work by you sample vertices you
look at the induced
graph and and then you sample them
uniformly
and at random this is yeah this is so it
makes it
so so this guarantees there is a delta
there is a probability
delta in these guarantees so there is
everything here is just with high
constant probability if you want and you
can make it you know 1 minus delta
uh by repetitions and taking if it's the
property testing
you know taking uh the majority decision
for the distance approximation taking
the median value
so so for us it's it's stated without
this depends but there is you can
enter in probability one minus delta the
answer will be
uh approximately correct so it's kind of
it is a probably approximately correct
type of thing
though it's not you know it's not
learning in the path model but it's the
same
flavor and in terms of kind of
conceptually
i i have a question you mentioned that
there's some work on sparse graphs so
is it like there's work on graphs of
bounded degree and there's work on dense
graphs and then
what about in between excellent right
this is uh so
okay so so there is um so kind of
again maybe a little bit historically so
this was kind of the first model that
jcc matrix prisma
would studied uh even before people talk
about property testing there were there
was since it's more related to what
people in combinatorics and then work so
so this was the dense one was the one
that was studied a lot
okay so then you're right one one model
would be the bounded degree
so then you will say okay everybody has
degree at most d
you can look at your d neighbors um and
then
at a general one the one that kind of
encompasses i would say
ev everything and will be the following
that you have
a bound or you know the number of edges
or you have about it can be
and it's not bound to degree but you
know the sparsity depends on
m so let's say it's even sparse but some
vertices may have very high degree
and then the distance measure will
depend on m so
it's the number of edges you are allowed
to say remove
as a function of the number of edges
that you have right so this is a model
that i mean i
i like that model a lot and it's that
was the most
it is the most general there are various
questions what type of queries you're
allowed
is it only neighbors can you only go to
your neighbors or maybe you can
ask both neighbor and queries of this
type so there are and there are
definitely there are there is work um in
this in this most uh
most uh uh uh general model uh the
results tend to be
tends to be harder you know because but
that's uh yeah
not surprising some even i'll say even
it's sometimes
you can get the whole spectrum between
you know bounded degree
and dense and sparse in the middle
you'll you'll get so in bipartisans
actually this is the case
that you can go from from can from the
bounded degree
um dependence on n is squared and the
dense
it's no dependence and in the middle it
degrades
the greatest incense in a good sense i
mean the number of queries goes
down as you become more dense yeah
the other
i i have just like a really general
question so
um i guess the impression i got from the
talks is that the best results
are obtained by these sort of
combinatorial observations
is that the the general state of the
okay good point okay
so um i would say that in the
dense and the dense graph though it's
not
um they're saying there isn't is are
there algorithmic questions kind of
maybe i don't know if this is what uh
because
it's um so first there is
the okay i'll say i'll say two two
things so one thing is actually
interesting in
ggr the paper that i mentioned before
about partition properties
so in terms of the algorithm they were
simple they you just
sample and you look at the induced
subgraph the analysis
actually didn't use something like a
known unknown characterization but
actually worked from first
principles about how you know
um how could you show that if somebody
is far then it will be
it will be it will be caught so it's not
always
dependent on common known combinatorial
facts but sometimes
sometimes it is um i think it
in a sense it's i mean i don't care you
know what is common it's always you know
these definitions what is combinatorial
you know when people say everything is
from georgia
but um instead of the flavor of things
so for example in the
bounded degree of sparse model there is
more the techniques will be say you know
you use random walks so you will
use things like like um what you know
about expanders
so there'll be like a different set of
tools that
that that you will use um so that's uh
that's kind of um kind of the spirit of
things though also in the in the
boundary degree in part there are also
people from combinatorial economics
working and they're also commentarial
flavor to it there's always in in the
ground but in other objects then
then less but i really talked over only
about that
okay so unless there are
more questions let's let's all thank
dana again for the fantastic talk
um and uh thank you
all right and i thought maybe we can try
a little experiment i really miss
this uh this time after the talk where
you sort of walk into the lobby and uh
you know have a coffee with your friends
so in the chat i'm going to post
a link to the um simon's institute
gather town
and anyone who wants to meet their um
you know i'll be there
to to have some small talk so okay
okay so can you send it because i can't
see the chat